Bella Ramsay may have never played the
video game but her role in the series
The Last of Us did teach her how to
swear with an American accent
you and when it comes to
Shenanigans on the set of The Last of Us
that's only the beginning for the car
ride scene production transformed the
entire town of Fort McCloud into
something that Pedro Pascal referred to
as an extreme version of Halloween
Horror Nights the amazing about formal
crowd is it was like you could just
really immerse yourself because it's all
in front of you as Pedro recalled the
experience of driving through the set
with a camera in the car while watching
mobs of infected chasing people and cars
almost hitting us as being the greatest
opportunity of playing make-believe I've
ever had I learned that American accent
by cursing essentially but she has a
good excuse the way Bella describes it
it was important to her to learn how to
swear properly because Ellie curses
every two seconds she worked with a
dialect coach and started out with some
super complex but less vulgar sounding
words like olive oil and if you're
wondering if that accent managed to
stick it all if I ever need to make a
phone call that's like important I do an
American accent how do you think you'd
respond to seeing the clickers in person
the third stage of infection was
represented by the show using practical
effects and you can even see the actors
just sort of hanging out on set wearing
the full costumes and speaking to Pedro
Pascal Bella Ramsay said you would very
grossed out by them I I was grossed out
while she argued that I found him sort
of beautiful they were beautiful but in
the end the two of them agreed that the
beauty of the clickers only like made
them that much more terrifying and they
described them as the kind of like
monstrous floral nightmares yeah oh and
by the way Bella Ramsay nearly turned
down the role of Ellie crazy right but
the way she described it I seriously
considered that maybe I don't want to be
famous so I'm not gonna do this show
because it's going to propel me to a
place I don't want to go in terms of
being seen and being known I like to
blend in and hide still out of everyone
who had auditioned including her Game of
Thrones co-star Maisie Williams Bella
was easily Neil druckman's favorite and
he described her by saying Bella felt so
real it was like Ellie realized in live
action it didn't feel like watching an
actor did you know Pedro Pascal has
never even played the games before he
said that he sought out the role of Joel
after watching Craig Mason's Chernobyl
which left him feeling that I would have
I don't know murdered somebody to work
with Craig and so on the day of his
audition Pedro called his sister to tell
her about this new job opportunity and
when her teenage Sons overheard they
were like The Last of Us you have to do
it you better get this job from this
response and so I understood very very
quickly what was uh what was what was
his stake from the moment you meet Sarah
it's important for you to love her she's
almost the protagonist until disaster
strikes while the game is able to form a
bond between you and Sarah by making her
a playable character the series didn't
really have that option so to make up
for that Craig Mason came up with the
idea of having the first episode open on
her perspective which like allows for
you to spend more moments with her alone
and so this also had the unexpected
benefit of allowing the series to ask
the question if an outbreak like this
happened what would it look like from a
kid's perspective Merle Dandridge has
already made herself synonymous with the
last of us after providing the voice for
Marlene on the games but for the show
she's stepped up to play her in live
action it's another thing to step in
front of the camera and embody her with
my own instrument Merle even admitted
that she didn't think she'd get the part
but from the moment she heard the show
was happening she knew one thing mommy
want that so when Bella showed up for
her first audition The Producers asked
if she'd ever played The Last of Us
games to which she responded with
something like have you played this
video game no I'm not a gamer and their
response keep it that way huh Bella did
break the rules a little bit and watched
some of the gameplay but explained they
didn't want me to copy Ashley Johnson's
iconic version of Ellie but bring a
fresh perspective I suppose so how many
locations can you recognize from the
game photo sets uploaded onto the Last
of Us news Twitter page showed just how
much painstaking detail went into
building these sets from the Yuri sign
welcoming you into Boston cuese to the
guard towers that look just like
something from the game Craig Mason
found that to be one of the most
important elements from it to include
several Easter eggs for fans of the
games but he also established the rule
that nothing could be included if it
wouldn't make sense to Casual viewers it
wasn't so much duplicating as as
honoring it was like well why would we
change it if it is lovely who knew we
almost missed our chance to see Pedro
Pascal in the role of Joel as it turns
out he had to get permission from the
producers of the Mandalorian in order to
even work on a rival company's project
he said that the producers very
generously gave him permission but that
wasn't the only reason why the
Mandalorian might have worked against
him being cast Craig Mason admitted that
he was a little bit hesitant to hire
Pedro due to certain similarities
between Joel and Pedro's character on
the Mandalorian such as the dynamic he
shares with baby Yoda in the end Mason
decided that the two relationships would
still come across as different enough
due to the fact that interacting with a
teenager is complicated don't
do the clickers on the show sound
familiar to you
that might be because they're voiced by
the same team who brought us the
clicker's distinctive sound for the
games
Misty Lee is a voice actress Who
provided many of the sounds herself
while Philip kovats served as the audio
director during the game's development
for the HBO series Misty Lee is credited
for playing the female clicker while
Philip kovats provides the voice for
male clicker having summarized his
experience on Twitter by saying Misty
and I had an absolute blast working with
Neil druckman and Craig Mason reprising
these characters and helping them come
alive okay well we all know that you
can't do the last of us without Troy
Baker and Ashley Johnson although the
voice actors who brought Joel and Ellie
from the games will not be reprising
their iconic roles on the series Craig
Mason has promised each of them other
roles in the series and honestly Troy
admitted that he didn't really expect to
play Joel in the live action anyway and
said that they were gonna see the
Aesthetics of me and it was just gonna
be so different and both he and Ashley
have given Pedro and Bella Their
Blessings we just love you as Joel and
Ellie thank you
you may recognize Pedro and Bella as
their game of throne characters so we
come from the same home birthing Place
yeah as much as this definitely made it
easier for the two of them to navigate
their working relationship it's it is
sort of a a bond that we have that
doesn't mean that things were all
sunshine and Roses Pedro can still
recall the time that he first got in
contact with Bella Ramsey and found
himself thinking how am I going to text
a 17 year old okay but like for all of
their attention to detail how well do
you think the HBO series did in
recreating the characters and visuals
from the game we'd love to hear your
thoughts so don't forget to make them
heard down below